I'm friends with Will Sasso who does the
um um a podcast he was on our podcast
and he talked about this Duty which is
do you know about this he's got an aid
driven podcast oh with his partner and
the partner is uh this genius who
actually wrote a book on how to win The
Bachelor you know bachelor Playbook and
he said you know that I'm I'm familiar
with the book yeah you are and he said
oh let me show you what he said to us
and then I want you to comment on this
sorry encyclopedic knowledge of reality
you need to go on Nick VI's podcast uh
yeah I don't think that's going to
happen he does like you stories for
another time Nick vial is very much what
wait go go what are you doing um what we
call a fence player he is not affiliated
uh legitimately with the show anymore
but he gets a lot of favors from them so
he has to kind of mind his P's and qes
about what he says we are very
definitely on the other side of that we
are trying to analyze the game for what
it is a game expose it as a game and win
that game wasn't there a show that came
out that was it was a scripted show
about the bachelor that was really
showing that's it wait wait what play
the clip that he like how prod what his
book does and he says that he win that's
a little bit before that that's a little
bit so you can expl do you know who he
is I'm I'm from I've seen his face
before okay it's been on that neck for
years the the what what I was saying
what he was saying was he wrote a book
on how to win The Bachelor and and and
that they've been caught on the set
reading that book and thrown off the off
the game cast members
yes I don't know maybe play before that
play before that but he says there's a
there's a definite game strategy yeah I
mean I I guess I disagree with that I
mean my understanding of these people is
ultimately they're just fans of the show
they've gotten very involved I mean
there's a competitive element to it but
I think it's
uh a what's the word I'm looking for I
don't know uh yeah
um that my experience on the show like
really affected me you know um while I
don't think I was ever really in love
for what I now feel like really love is
to me um I felt real pain and real
sadness and real heartbreak when I was
The Bachelor even for the women I wasn't
going to end up with uh I felt real
remorse and real guilt because on some
level you have to be misleading and you
have to lead people on I tried to be
very respectful for that as much as I
could and so I think and everyone's
experience is different the people who
make it to the final four uh they have a
very different experience on that show
rather than the people who are there for
night one or a couple weeks I always
find it kind of hilarious that the
people who usually go home the first
week or two have the most to say about
how the show Works in public you know
but it's you know the people who make
the final four are literally there twice
as long
uh like how long is the whole thing
depending on the season but historically
typically it's about nine weeks and you
get to the final four within the first
five and a half six weeks so again the
final four they're almost twice as long
as anyone else but I guess my point is
is like listen like they're having fun I
think they're kind of um I my my
question for them is I wonder how
serious they are about their analysis of
the show but to me again like there uh
we the people who go on that show it's
it's it's it was my life for a b part of
uh for a big part of my 30s and I had a
lot of ups and a lot of downs and a a
lot of Trauma from it and a lot of
experiences and to have that be
suggested that it's all just a game and
it's all fake and no one's sincere and
it's all just you know uh gamesmanship I
think is disingenuous the people who've
had real feelings and real emotions and
had to deal with some real uh Trauma
from that
environment
he